the concept of entropy is related to the
idea of microstates and to think about
microstates let's consider one mole of
an ideal gas so remember n represents
moles at a specific pressure volume and
temperature
if the system of gas particles is at
equilibrium then the pressure the volume
the number of moles and the temperature
all remain the same so from a
macroscopic point of view nothing seems
to be changing
however from a microscopic point of view
things are changing all of the time so
looking at our gas particles here in the
first box imagine these gas particles
slamming into the sides of the container
and maybe slamming into each other and
transferring energy from one particle to
another so if we think about the
particles in our system at one moment in
time in box one if we think about them
at a different moment in time in box two
the particles might be in slightly
different positions and the velocities
might have changed
remember that the speed of a particle
tells us how fast the particle is
traveling however when we put an arrow
on each particle that also gives us the
direction and the magnitude and the
direction give a velocity so these
arrows on these particles are meant to
represent the velocities of the
particles
and the kinetic energy of each particle
is equal to one half m v squared where m
is the mass of each particle and v is
the velocity
a microstate refers to a microscopic
arrangement of all of the positions and
energies of the gas particles since
we're dealing with an ideal gas here by
energies we're referring to the kinetic
energies of the particles
so going back to our boxes box one box
two and box three each box shows a
different microscopic arrangement of
positions and energies of the gas
particles
therefore each box represents one
microstate
a good way to think about a microstate
would be like taking a picture of our
system of gas particles so from a
macroscopic point of view nothing seems
to change but taking a picture at the
microscopic level we see that the system
is moving from one microstate into
another into another into another so the
number of microstates available to this
system of one mole of gas particles is a
number that's too high for us to even
comprehend
now that we understand the concept of
microstates let's look at an equation
developed by boltzmann that relates
entropy to the number of microstates
according to this equation entropy
symbolized by s is equal to boltzmann's
constant k
times the natural log of w and w
represents the number of microstates in
a system so if the number of microstates
of a system increases that represents an
increase in entropy
and if the number of microstates
decreases that represents a decrease in
the entropy of the system
sometimes instead of using the word
microstates people will describe an
increase in entropy as an increase in
disorder or an increase in the dispersal
of either matter or energy sometimes
using these terms helps us think about
entropy however when we're using the
equation developed by boltzmann we
should think about these terms as
meaning an increase in the number of
microstates and therefore an increase in
the entropy of the system
and if we think about a decrease in the
disorder of the system or an increase in
the order or a decrease in the dispersal
of either matter or energy that really
relates to a decrease in the number of
available microstates which means a
decrease in the entropy of the system
next let's think about the change in
entropy for a number of different
situations in our first situation we're
starting off with one mole of an ideal
gas so here are the gas particles in a
container and the container has a
removable divider separating the
container into two compartments let's
say we go ahead and remove the divider
and now our gas particles are free to
travel around in a larger volume so if
the initial volume is v1 let's say we
have twice the volume for the final
volume therefore v2 or the final volume
is equal to two times v1 the number of
moles remains the same so n1 is equal to
one mole of our ideal gas and n2 is also
equal to one mole so n2 is equal to n1
during the expansion of the gas the
temperature is kept constant therefore
the initial temperature t1 is equal to
the final temperature t2 next let's
think about what happens to the number
of available microstates when the volume
is doubled when the volume is doubled
that increases the number of possible
positions for the gas particles
therefore the number of microstates
increases
and looking at our equation if the
number of microstates increases
then so does the entropy
therefore we can say that s2 is greater
than s1 and thinking about the change in
the entropy delta s if s2 is greater
than s1 then s2 minus s1 would be a
positive value therefore the change in
entropy
for the free expansion of a gas when the
temperature is constant is positive
for our next situation we're starting
once again with one mole of an ideal gas
however this time the volume will be
held constant and the temperature will
be increased so we start with one mole
of our ideal gas at a certain volume so
n1 and v1 and we are increasing the
temperature but we're not changing the
number of moles or the volume therefore
the final number of moles n2 is equal to
the initial number n1 which is one mole
and the final volume v2 is equal to the
initial volume v1 since we are
increasing the temperature the final
temperature t2 is greater than the
initial temperature t1 next let's use a
maxwell boltzmann distribution over here
on the right to explain what we see in
our particulate diagrams on the left in
the particular diagram on the left we
can see that the particles are moving
with different velocities or different
magnitudes or speeds and we can see that
by the length of the arrows in the box
and that's what the maxwell boltzmann
distribution tells us here so for the
one in blue we know that there are a
range of speeds available to the
particles so the area under the curve
represents all of the particles in the
gas sample so some are moving at a
slower speed some are moving at a higher
speed but most of them are moving at a
speed close to the center of this peak
increasing the temperature means that
the on average the particles are moving
faster so we can see that on average the
length of these arrows is is longer than
the length of the arrows in the
particular diagram on the left but it
also means if we look at the maxwell
boltzmann distribution there are greater
range of speeds available to the
particles and if there's a greater range
of speeds or greater range of velocities
that means there's a greater range of
kinetic energies which means there are
more possible microstates available to
the system of gas particles therefore
increasing the temperature causes an
increase in the number of possible
microstates
and an increase in the number of
microstates means an increase in the
entropy
therefore the final entropy s2 is
greater than the initial entropy s1 so
when we think about the change in
entropy delta s for the system if s2 is
greater than s1 the change in entropy is
positive so for a system of gas
particles with constant volume and
constant number of moles if we increase
the temperature there's an increase in
the entropy
for our next situation we're once again
starting with one mole of an ideal gas
at a certain temperature t1 and a
certain volume v1
this time we're going to increase the
number of moles from one mole of an
ideal gas to two moles of an ideal gas
so if we had four particles on the left
now we have eight particles in the
diagram uh in the particulate diagram on
the right so the final number of moles
n2 is greater than the initial number n1
but we're going to keep the temperature
the same so the final temperature is
equal to the initial temperature and
we're going to keep the volume constant
too so v2 where the final volume is
equal to the initial volume v1
because we have increased the number of
particles there are more possible
arrangements of particles and also more
ways to distribute the energy therefore
when we increase the number of moles
there's an increase in the number of
possible microstates
and increasing the number of microstates
in a system increases the entropy
therefore the final entropy s2 is
greater than the initial entropy s1 and
once again the change in entropy if s2
is greater than s1 would be positive so
increasing the number of moles of gas
particles increases the entropy of the
system for our next situation let's
consider the evaporation of liquid water
into gaseous water water molecules in
the liquid state are held together by
intermolecular forces
with hydrogen bonding being the most
important intermolecular force holding
the particles together water molecules
in the liquid state are still free to
move however when water molecules in the
liquid state get converted into water
molecules in the gaseous state we assume
there are no more intermolecular forces
between the gas particles so we're
assuming this is an ideal gas and if
there are no intermolecular forces
between the gas particles we've
increased the freedom of movement of the
water molecules we've increased the
number of possible positions and
therefore we've increased the number of
microstates available and if we increase
the number of microstates we increase
the entropy therefore thinking about the
entropy change this would be the final
entropy s2 minus the initial entropy s1
and since the entropy increased going
from liquid water to gaseous water the
change in entropy would be positive this
is also one example where thinking about
entropy in terms of disorder can be
helpful because gases are more
disordered than liquids you could say
and therefore going from a liquid to a
gas increases the amount of disorder
which increases the entropy but remember
really disorder is really just a way to
describe an increased number of
available microstates for our final
situation let's look at a reaction that
involves only gases
on the left side we can see there's two
moles of so2 and one mole of o2 so there
are three moles of gas on the reactant
side and on the product side there are
two moles of gas
next let's think about the change in
entropy for this reaction delta s that'd
be equal to the final entropy minus the
initial entropy so thinking about the
initial entropy s1 and the final entropy
s2 we went from 3 moles of gas to 2
moles of gas remember that a decrease in
the number of moles of gas means a
decrease in the number of possible
microstates that means a decrease in the
entropy therefore s2 is less than s1 or
we could say that s1 is greater than s2
therefore for the change in the entropy
if s1 is greater than s2 we're
subtracting a larger number from a
smaller number which means the change in
entropy for this reaction delta s will
be negative
so as a quick summary when trying to
figure out the change in entropy we need
to consider the number of available
microstates if the number of available
microstates increases then the change in
entropy is positive if the number of
available microstates decreases then the
change in entropy is negative